that's how I want you don't know for who
you pretend that you know but you don't
know dribbles that I really have to
disagree with life in a lot of time with
this time I'm open-minded you are not
mr. Carlson what happened to you man
you used to be affable used to be
friendly used to wear a nice tie now you
wear one of those bibs and I don't know
so I don't know what happened to you man
but I want you to consider that from the
scientific perspective pick the number
you like 97% of the world scientists
very close to 100% of the world
scientists are very concerned about
climate change and so why aren't some
people concerned about it when media
outlets were allowed to be consolidated
in the 1980s then it developed these two
factions like that I don't remember it
having and by that I think two factions
are a normal course of events where you
have males and females and boys and
girls whether it's fruit flies or
dandelions or you and me and in the
World Cup soccer you end up with two
teams the World Series Baseball you end
up with two teams it's really hard to
have three teams and so I think and we
too two political parties nominally so
somebody who understands this better
than I do may observe that the media
have divided into two camps but from our
point of view and the science
engineering side you got a respect to
facts at some level you got a respect of
its scientifically provable and then
speaking of authorities and mistrust of
authorities the crowd on at the
inauguration
I was objectively smaller crowd than the
crowd the next day at the Women's March
so when you if someone is searched that
that crowd is bigger when it was clearly
smaller than everything else he or she
says is subject to question and this has
led to a lot of trouble so I think
though that built in to the US
government which includes
the First Amendment of the Bill of
Rights is freedom of the press built-in
is change so I'm very hopeful I'm
optimistic that things will change that
my understanding is subscriptions to
so-called mainstream media Washington
Post New York Times and so on have gone
up in response to these to this approach
to objective truths so that will
probably be to the good but how or fast
what happened and what will go wrong in
the meantime this is these are big
questions and then as far as my thing
but mr. Carlson I don't know he used to
not interview that way he used to not
just talk right you don't have to change
it I'm just saying you don't actually
know because it's unknowable this is why
although they can bundle up me okay it
takes you quite a bit less than six
seconds I go back again in a second mr.
Carlson if you have me on again I'll
come right back on bring it on man and
you know what else mr. Carlson I'll bet
you $10,000 that 2010-2020 will be the
hottest decade on record I offered a bed
of ten thousand dollars to Joe Bastardi
who is a Fox News contributor and Marc
Morano who I'm not sure as a contributor
but used to appear on your station
routinely your network routinely I bet
them each 10,000 bucks 2010 2020 to be
the hottest decade on record I bet them
each another tenth oh they say twenty
ten thousand bucks on the decade ten
thousand bucks on the year 2016 2016
would have been among the top ten
hottest years on record wait there's
more
2016 was the hottest year on record and
your guys the people that foxnews
heretofore supports and this would not
take either bet $40,000 wouldn't take
the bet could have been theirs I'm good
for it
[Music]